hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game
that was played in 2012 in the european
club cup a lot of you have suggested it
over the
course of time but the latest suggestion
comes from
zarif tamid ship so thank you for the
suggestion i haven't seen the game
and yes it features uh well not another
spectacular move over or anything just a
spectacular series of moves that
uh really make this game unique and it's
uh probably better than the last movie
you've seen
and it's definitely better than the last
movie i've seen i've seen the new mortal
kombat movie
and i'm a huge fan of the franchise i'm
a big fan of the uh old school mortal
kombat movie
and it was just um it was just i i don't
know what to say
but uh you know just putting that out
there uh so that being said let's check
out this game which is nothing like the
new mortal kombat movie
uh without further ado let's check out
what's happening here uh as
anish giri faces maxim rochester and
it's uh
it's a really well it is just one of
those games that you have to show you
show everyone especially your friend
your good friends at the bar in the
library
and uh geary opens with the knight to f3
so
that the reti is on the board we have
knight to f6
c4 and b6 now we have d4 by geary
uh and now bishop to b7 i'm going for a
sort of a queens indian setup here and
this was uh well before
uh the alpha zero showed us the way
on how not to play the queen's indian
defense uh and here we have
g3 gary prepares to counter black's uh
light square bishop by fingering his own
bishop uh we have g6
uh black wants to be in cairo the other
bishop as well and
now comes bishop to g2 we have bishop to
g7 and both players castle now so
castles castles and
d5 now gary grabs more space in the
center and now
maxine goes uh well uh proceeds with a
principled idea and he attacks
uh this uh advanced pawn by playing e6
you could also play
c6 but doesn't really uh change anything
all that much
if anything it's not as good for black
for example knight c3 you could trade
captures capture z6 and now e4 and
both white and black retain the the
strong center
so here instead after d5 we have the
immediate e6
and now knight to c3 we have e captures
on the 5c
e5 and now rook to e8 uh we have rook to
e1
and now uh maxine plays c6 uh in this
position
he uh sort of tries to undermine white's
uh strong advanced
d5 pawn and not only is was this a new
move in the position in 2012 but it is
also a move that has never been played
again since
so let's see how geary dealt with this
he played e4
uh we have d6 now making room for the
night the knight cannot come for example
to d7 maybe to e5
uh and bishop to f4 anish continues
development we have
c captures e captures and now rook
captures an a1
any one we have queen captures any one
and now
again you have to be very careful the d5
pawn seems like it's
weak and it's it looks like you could
capture it maybe with knight captures on
d5
but then we just capture for example
captures captures and then rook to d1
and all of a sudden how are you
uh defending the there's no way to
defend the light square bishop
and once the bishop moves you're just
gonna pick up the d6 pawn
and now it's uh trouble for black white
is up in development
and the white uh does have a better
position you still have to develop your
knight to get the rook into the game
and white is just controlling uh much
more space so instead after queen
captures an e1
we have knight to a6 uh maksim now wants
to pile up on this pawn the knight
and the bishop are already attacking it
the knight will come to c7 and from c7
will add more pressure to the d5 pawn
and
now uh knight the d4 now the bishop and
the knight
guard this pawn we have queen to d7
making room for the rook to come into
the game maybe rook to e8 maybe rook to
ca depending on what on each place
and now rook to d1 a nice centralized
move with the rook if this pawn is
attacked one more time then you can move
the knight and
you will add additional protection to
this spawn which is exactly what happens
in the game
knight c7 a third attacker joins the
party and now
knight back to c2 we have rooked the c8
and now
uh end now comes queen to e2
developing the queen grabbing more
control over the light squares here as
you can see now the queen is
much much stronger here controlling this
controlling this controlling all of this
so it's uh a much much more active
square for the queen than e1
we have knight the h5 now putting
pressure on the bishop
and this is where the fun really starts
here anish could go back with the bishop
let's say bishop back to d2
and if you don't know what you're doing
bishop to d2 is probably the safest
way to play this game but it would seem
that anish
knows exactly what he's doing and here
he played bishop to g5
now leaving the c3 knight exposed and
okay capturing on c3 does seem like an
unprincipled decision because this is
just a monster bishop
and once uh you get if you trade it for
a night even
by winning the material which is in this
case winning a pawn
uh you will be left with your pawns on
light squares and with nothing in
between to help defend
the dark square so uh here maxim does go
for it bishop captures on c3 and yes it
does win material
b captures and now knight to b5 with a
double attack on the c3 pawn
and there's no way to defend the c3 pawn
if you advance the pawn to c4 just
knight c3 and
there's a nice fork here you will you
will lose material
so instead after knight to b5 gary
simply played rook to e1 and
the this is uh you have to follow
everything that ha
that's happening here because the magic
already started where
when anish played bishop to g5 so here
rook to e1
giving up the c3 pawn we have knight
captures on c3
attacking the queen and the a2 pawn now
also uh
still attacking that d5 pawn queen to d2
and now comes the bishop captures on d5
grabbing yet
another pawn uh because yes you you can
capture here twice
but the knight will be hanging on c2 so
here
bishop captures on d5 was played knight
captures we have queen captures and
rook captures on c2 not only is maxine
uh up to pawn up two pawns now but he
has a very active rook and he's
already attacking the his next target
but
giri now has rook to e7 and this is a
very
very dangerous move it doesn't seem like
it's doing anything and it's
really not uh but it is
yeah so here gary goes for it rook to e7
now you have to react to this actively
because then queen captures an f7 check
followed by queen captures on h7
uh checkmate is coming so here rook the
c1
with check and this is a fine idea uh if
the
bishop here grabs the rook then the
queen can capture on e7 so
black would just be better now so
instead after rook to c1 check we have
king to g2
only other good move and now the the way
you save the game
queen to c6 and it seems uh maxime
decided uh to give up the a7 pawn but he
will save the game and he will
have an extra pawn so i know what you're
thinking you're thinking okay but why
are you showing us this game
what's so special about it gary try gary
blunder he's down pawn he's gonna
struggle in the end game
uh well let's see what happens here
queen captures on c6 we have rook
captures on c6
and now rook captures on a7 and now you
can see we have an end game here
a bishop and uh rook against the rook
and the knight where
uh maxine is up a pawn
so let's see uh how geary goes about
this because this is where the fun
really starts okay the fun really
started with that bishop the g5 move
uh but now how do you continue the game
with black how do you get the knight
into the game that's the real question
here
this is covered by the pawn this is
covered by the bishop you can't really
go knight g7 to try and bring the knight
back into the game this way
because then you just blunder the knight
you deliver check and here you you will
have to give up that knight so here
maxim tries another idea king the g7
and now he will be able to bring the
knight into the game via the f6 square
but giri doesn't allow it bishop to e3
and now again what do you play here the
knight is still unable to join the game
and without the deny being able to join
the game
you're basically down a piece for the
rest of the game so here
knights to f6 he tries it but now bishop
to d4
and he says nope that knight is not uh
going to be a part of this game
at all we have b5 and now comes
rook to a5 attacking the b5 pawn we have
rook to c4
attacking the bishop trying to get the
bishop to move so so the knight can join
the action as well but now bishop back
to a1 we have rooked the c1
attacking the bishop and now bishop to
b2 and now the problem is if you play
rook to c2 to keep harassing the bishop
then just rook captures on b5 defense
the bishop and the a pawn is now winning
for anish
so obviously that's uh not happening and
if you play something like d5 saying
okay but i also have a past pawn then
just rook here
and you're you're losing the game the
knight is now lost uh there's no way to
play this or or you have to give up the
rook for bishop and then it's again lost
so here after bishop to b2 we have
rooked the c5
uh by maxim and now the game is
completely winning for giri
but the move that gear replayed is a
spectacular one
uh it's totally invisible to the engines
it doesn't matter how strong your engine
is
so feel free to put or maybe it isn't is
you know i've
let the engine crunch the numbers to
unimaginable depths
and uh the the move is still
elusive to the engine so feel free to
pause the video here and
find this amazing idea for a niche while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on being
as strong as a niche and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
it's a4 and a4 is just a
spectacular idea here because uh well
obviously it's it's a pawn you can grab
it but if you don't capture it
uh then uh white will just uh white will
just capture on b5 and then you'll be
down a pawn and
white will win this game easily so here
uh
roshan captured b captures on a4 and now
what's happening here should giri grab
the pawn back or not
well giri decided to trade rooks here
rook
captures on c5 we have d captures on c5
and now again we get this position where
gary is down two pawns however this is
completely winning for him
so once again feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the winning
idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
uh not like not doing anything weird
here
you know don't do uh some king movements
or bishop movements if you do
that then you allow black to play g5 if
you allow black to play g5
then he frees up the g6 square for his
king and that's it here you have to play
f4 or h4 if you do that then you cover
the g5 square and that's it black
has no moves gear we played f4 h4 also
works it doesn't really matter the point
is that
now there is nothing you can do now if
you if you force g5 to clear this square
for the king
then f captures and then the knight is
pinned we're just going to win it and
then
easily win the game so what you could do
here
is try to waste some moves which is what
maksim does he played a3
trying to get giri to capture with the
bishop so he can unpin and move the
knight
but anish just played bishop to a1 and
it was in this position on move 37 that
maximum rochester resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
really
an amazing game a masterpiece if you
will
and uh i haven't seen this game so far
so thank you everyone for suggesting it
and
it's uh well yeah i'm going to show you
why it's uh
completely uh resignable because i know
most of you enjoy it when i do that
uh so here black has to make a move it
doesn't matter what movie
you make uh white's moves are
very clear just g for g5 and that's it
we win the game
so if you try something like h6 to try
and force g5 just
h4 we do not allow black to use the g5
square
h5 or something you have to waste the
move king of three
and now if c4 we can just you know move
the bishop back and forth until
uh black runs out of moves so for
example a2 we're just gonna play bishop
something then a1 queen we can just
capture that if c3 or something we're
going to capture that as well
and now black again has to make a move
if he moves the king then bishop
captures knight and then we have a
winning end game
and if you play something like g5 then
finally f captures on g5 and on the next
move we win the night and we win the
game
so an outstanding outstanding game and
it's really hard to even uh
imagine uh at the what at what point in
the game did anish
know that this was winning so some say
you know
the legend says that here when he didn't
go bishop back to d2 where he played
bishop to g5 that he already knew here
but
that's hard to say i mean because if you
if you just allow this
pawn grab uh it's it's it's very hard to
say
okay the the bishop controlling all of
the dark squares in front of the black
king is compensation in itself i would
say
uh but still it's not uh not not easy to
spot shot
spot such moves because the queen uh the
queen trade was
imminent and then here i mean it's just
a a wonderful wonderful game
uh something that you can definitely use
in your own games if you
you know if such an idea is possible in
the position maybe you can
you know give up some material to weaken
some squares in front of your opponent's
king then he doesn't have a bishop you
have a bishop you know
good things will happen so like i said
after bishop to a1
roshan resigned the game and this
amazing amazing game
was played by anish giri uh so
uh that's the game hope you guys uh
enjoyed it and here once again uh i
uh you know i cannot stress enough how
the how important uh it is for you guys
to use
use hashtag suggestion i'm not gonna see
all of them i'm not gonna be able to
cover all of them but you know
either in the comments or by email or on
twitter or on any social media you know
uh at some point i will reach it because
i just go uh
you know i load up the comments i search
for hashtag suggestion
then i list them then i go through them
and then i check out the games and then
we get to see such such amazing amazing
games
uh but yeah i hope you guys enjoyed that
one i would like to thank uh daniel and
martin heming
uh oscar brent costus before and after
gordon goodman and joffrey rosenstein
for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day